a presidential visit to the front lines
Vladimir zalinski awarding medals to
Ukrainian troops in Kuban of course
emotionally they need some support I
think it's
very that support internationally
starting to wne after the Israel Hamas
conflict has taken up considerable
Western
attention zinsky conceding only the
blind could not recognize the impact the
Middle East conflict is having on
Ukraine but urging the war world not to
forget about the war in his country so
much for making a message backed up by
the head of NATO the NATO doesn't have
the luxury of only been able to address
one challenge at the time we need to be
able to address different
challenges NATO member Hungary
challenging Ukraine's bid to join the
European
Union potential negotiations to join the
block are not in hungary's National
interest says prime minister Victor
Orbin who's considered one of Russian
President Vladimir Putin's closest
allies the leader of the conservatives
is cozying up to Russian dictator
Vladimir Putin a similar claim leveled
against Canadian conservatives by the
Liberals this week after Tories voted
against updating the Canada Ukraine Free
Trade Agreement because they say it
would impose a carbon tax on Keith these
issues about carbon pricing didn't
really come up the Ukrainian Canadian
Congress pushing back noting the
agreement does not force a carbon tax
and even if it did Ukraine has had one
in place since 2011 it's clear sort of
what the text of the the text of the the
agreement says and then what Ukraine
itself is saying the UCC has now ridden
directly to piev asking for the
conservatives to reconsider their
opposition to the deal far but even if
they don't it's still likely to pass the
House of Commons McKenzie gry and Ottawa
thank you McKenzie